foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
the invasive niche of the basal cell
carcinoma as revealed by integrated
multi-omics this webinar is part of the
cancer research and immuno oncology
virtual week and I'm Susie Valdez of
Labyrinth and I will be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by labroots and
sponsored by nanostring Technologies for
more information about nanostring go to
nanostring.com now let's get started
before we begin I want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to First
participate by communicating with other
attendees using our new live chat
feature during the presentation you can
find that live chat located on the left
of your screen you can also participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want during this presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click submit we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
now if you are having any trouble seeing
or hearing this presentation just click
on that help desk button located at the
bottom of your screen within the
navigation bar or from the lobby and
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
that continuing education credit link
located in the abstract window to the
left on the screen and follow the
process to obtain those credits I now
present today's speaker Laura yearly a
PhD student at Lowe's in University
Hospital for a complete biography of our
speaker please visit the biography tab
at the left of your screen Ms yearly
welcome you may now begin your
presentation
hi everyone I will present you today our
work where we show all medium mix
integration reveals cellular and
molecular interactions governing the
invasive niche of basal cell carcinoma
two more cell invasion is the Hallmark
of cancer
the more cells invade the surrounding
tissue to escape starvation
and two more cell Invasion can lead to
metastasis and is associated with poor
prognosis
it is known that tumor microenvironment
plays an important role in tumor cell
Invasion however it is still poorly
understood which cells are interacting
with the tumor cells and what
interaction is happening so in order to
understand a bit better these
interactions we decided to use basal
cell carcinoma as a model
is a skin cancer it is the most frequent
human cancer worldwide and the speed
genetic homogeneity through defect in
the Ajax signaling pathway basal cell
carcinoma can display different clinical
and histopathological Spectrum
in fact basal cell carcinoma can be
divided in different subtypes the
nodular BCC subtype showing no
infiltration and often surrounded by
your basement membrane suggesting that
there is low interaction with the
surrounding stromal cells
carcinoma can also be divided in a
infiltrative subtype which form single
cell strand infiltrates without basement
membrane suggesting eye interaction with
the surrounding stromal cells
furthermore recent studies showed that
Gene's characterizing infiltrative bccs
through RNA SEC analysis or
extracellular Matrix remodeling genes
however this is not black and white
there is a kind of gradient between
nodular and infiltrative BCC subtypes
suggesting that tumor and stroma have
transcriptional reprogramming
so our question was can we
transcriptionally characterize two more
and stromal cells composing the invasive
niche
so to this end we started by performing
digital special profiling with the
geomix technology of nanostring
on nodular and infiltrative bccs we took
biopsies
that withstand response cytokeratin
antibody and contesting with Concept
transcriptome Atlas probes then we draw
region of interest at the tumor stroma
interface
then based on the presence or absence of
bonsai to keratin staining the region of
Interest were divided in two area of
Interest the two more area of interest
if the Bonsai to keratin staining was
positive and the stroma area of Interest
operating staining was negative
then the regions were UV cleaved and
sequenced
and then we perform data analysis
so
from the tumor area of Interest we
extracted signatures
so we extracted a special two more
nodular signature from the tumor
nodular area of interest and we
extracted a special to more infiltrative
signature from the infiltrative to more
area of Interest
when we look at the PCA plot we observe
that the signature segregate well the
different BCC subtypes
we perform the same from the stromal
part so we extracted a special storm a
nodular signature from the nodular
stroma area of interest and a special
infiltrative signature from the
infiltrative stroma area of Interest
when we look at the PCA plot we see that
here again we have a good segregation
between the subtype stroma area of
Interest
then we have the limitation that we
don't have a single cell resolution so
to contract this limitation we decided
to perform single celebrity sequencing
on five infiltrative bccs so we
automatically
dissociated five fresh by two more
biopsies then we fact sorted single
living cells perform chromium 10x single
cell Arena SEC and analyze the data
we obtained the expected cell subtypes
we have epithelial cells T cells
melanocytes nanoid cells endothelial
cells fibroblasts cycling cells
parasites mast cells and B cells but
with a single cell we don't have the
special location of those cells so to
contract this limitation
we decided to combine both techniques
and
we applied the special signatures
obtained from digital special profiling
to the Single Cell RNA seg data
when we applied the spatial tumor
signature it highlights the two more
cells and when we applied those specials
trauma signature it highlighted the
particular cell types which are the
fibroblasts suggesting that special
signatures identifies two more cells and
fibroblasts composing two more stroma
interface in the invasive niche
then we wanted to characterize a bit
further those two cell types
so we started with the two more cells we
subclusterized the two more cells and
then
applied the difference between two more
infiltrative and two more nodular
signature scores
and we can see that we have a region
that is blue and is enriched for two
more nodular signature and then a
gradient going toward the red region
that is enriched for the two more
infiltrative signature
so we decided to rank the Clusters
according to the signature score of the
difference
from lowly infiltrative to Eileen
filtrative
then we characterized a bit further
those two more cells by looking for
differentiation signature of
keratinocytes and we observe that we
have an enrichment for basal signature
in the lowly infiltrative region and for
differentiation signature in the Eileen
filtrative clusters
suggesting that two more cells with
their gradual infiltrative phenotype
have also differentiation
a gradual differentiation phenotype
then
we were interested to know how those
cells migrate and to this end we look at
different migration signature so first
we look for epithelial Thomas and female
transition signature and we observe that
we have no particular enrichment for
this signature
but when we applied the collective
migration signature it highlights the
region where we have the highly
infiltrative tumor cells
suggesting that our
two more cells show a gradual
infiltrative phenotype with higher
Collective migration features than EMT
then we wanted to take advantage of the
pseudo-time analysis and look whether we
can
recapitulate our findings so we take a
starting point the low infiltrative
cluster and we observe that it
illustrates the infiltrative phenotype
because we have a decrease of the
nodular micro genes along the episode
time and an increase of the infiltrative
marker genes along the pseudo time this
was confirmed by fish
so in the lowly infiltrative region we
observe that we have a high level of the
nodular marker Gene and the low level of
the infiltrative marker Gene in the
medium infiltrative region we have an
intermediate
uh
signal of the
infiltrative marker and an intermediate
signal of the nodular marker and when we
go in the highly infiltrative region we
have a high expression of the
infiltrative marker and an absence of
the nodular one
then we confirmed our results by looking
at the
basal marker genes and we see that they
are decreasing along the episode of time
whereas differentiation markers were
increasing along the episode Time
trajectory as well as collective
migration markers
then we wanted to characterize the other
cell types so the fibroblast we applied
the difference between stroma
infiltrative and stromanodular signature
scores and we observe here that we have
again a region that is blue and which
forced from a nodular signature and then
a gradient toward the red where we have
an enrichment for this from an
infiltrative signature so we ranked
again the Clusters from lowly in
figurative to highly infiltrative
then we wanted to characterize the
fibroblast further and apply a consular
Associated fibroblast signature and we
observed that both fibroblasts are
running lowly infiltrative tumor cells
and fibroblasts are running highly
infiltrative to more cells or enrich for
this signature however when we look at
the heat map we observed that the genes
responsible for the signatory enrichment
are different between the fibroblasts
are running highly filtrative tumors and
the one surrounding lowly infiltrative
tumors
so to characterize them a bit further we
decided to look at different cell expert
genes between the fc4 cluster
surrounding Eileen filtrative cells and
the fc1 cluster surrounding lowly
infiltrative cells and we observe that
we have an enrichment in the fc4 for
extracellular Matrix organization and
extracellular structure organization
genes suggesting that the gaffe found in
the invasive Niche Arbor extracellular
Matrix remodeling features
so we can summarize the first part so we
showed that infiltrative tumors show a
gradual infiltrative phenotype going
from low to medium and iodine figurative
that the island filtrative two more
cells display differentiation and
Collective migration features and that
the Eileen figurative tumor cells are
surrounded by extracellular matrix
remodeling gaps
then we wondered whether we can infer
across talk between specially connected
tumor cells and gas
and to this end we decided to look for
the enrichment of cancer Associated
fibroblast activator
and we observe that we have a particular
enrichment of the nhba gene
in the island filtrative clusters
so in HBA is a gene encoding for active
in a
and active in a is the homogeneous of
the inibin subunit beta a it is a member
of the teacher better super family
activity is a secreted protein known as
calf activator
furthermore
compromise all published recently that
active in a promotes carcinogenesis via
fibroblast reprogramming in squamous
cell carcinoma which is another kind of
skin cancer so this was interested for
us because
we decided to look whether our
fibroblasts were influenced by the
presence of active in a
so we decided to apply the published
activity exposure signature and we
observed that the signature was
particularly enriched in the fc4 cluster
corresponding to the fibroblast
surrounding the Eileen filtrative two
more cells
so we confirmed this finding by
performing fish and we observe that in
The Superficial part of the tumor where
we have lowly infiltrative tumor cells
we have a low expression of in HPA and a
lower expression of fibronectin one in
the surrounding fibroblasts so
fibronectin one is a member of the
active in a exposure signature
but when we go deeper in the tumor we
have Island filtrative tumors that show
a high level of in HBA and we have also
a high expression of fibronectin one in
the surrounding fibroblasts
so with this we can conclude that our we
showed that in figurative tumors have a
gradual infiltrative phenotype from low
to medium and highly infiltrative that
the island filtrative two more cells
display differentiation and Collective
migration features
and that Island feature did two more
cells are surrounded by extracellular
matrix remodeling gas
and when we zoom in the invasive Niche
we have a high expression of in HPA in
the Eileen filtrative tumor cells that
encodes for active in a and active in a
acts on the surrounding extracellular
Matrix remodeling gas
so with this I would like to
particularly thank my Pi Franco and my
colleague Christine and all the other
people who worked on this study and I
will be happy to answer to questions
thank you Laura for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of this webinar and if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box located at the far left
of your screen so let's get started it
looks like we already have a couple
questions coming in Laura
our first question
did you have any contamination between
the tumor and stroma aois in the spatial
experiment
so yes we at some when we looked at the
genes present in the to more signature
and in the stroma signature some genes
were overlapping
so in order to take out the
contaminating genes we looked in the
single cell data whether the gene was
present for example a gene in the tumor
signature if it was mostly expressed in
the stromal part we removed it from the
to more signature
and also if it was equally expressed
between two more and stromal cells we
also removed it we kept only the genes
that were more expressed in the
two more cells compared to this trauma
in the tumor signature and we did the
same for the stromal part
thank you so much and why did
we have so many immune cells in
comparison to fibroblasts in the scrna
seek experiment
so this might be due to the dissociation
protocol because immune cells are more
can more easily be isolated than
fibroblasts that are adherent to The
Matrix and the infiltrative diseases or
known to be really fibrotic so there is
a lot of extracellular metrics
so this might be the cause why we don't
have so many fibroblasts
thank you so much and Laura did you have
any closing remarks for our audience
today it looks like that was the last
question coming in at this time
so just thank you to attend to this
webinar and for the question
well thank you Laura you're Elite for
your presentation today and your
important research and before we go I do
want to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions and I'd like to thank our
sponsors nanostring Technologies for
sponsoring today's webinar questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided us at
the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed on demand for two
years until October 4th 2024. lab Roots
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who missed today's live event until next
time take care everyone bye-bye